yeah series seven is rough whoo boy
there there's some real clunkers there's
a lot of mediocrity
and even the best episodes of this
series you put them up against the best
episodes of from any other series and
they don't even come close so series
seven is a rough go but I finished my
revisit I need to rank these suckers
let's go now there are no two parters in
this one and I'm gonna do something I
don't only do I'm counting the Christmas
special because it comes in the middle
of the series and as part of the series
arc so normally I don't include
Christmas specials when I do these
rankings I'm gonna make an exception
with series 7 so I've got 14 of these to
do let's get started number 14 journey
to the centre of the TARDIS what a great
title what a great idea what a lack of a
need for monsters what a lack for a need
of a stupid pointless twist on some guy
we don't know turning out to not
actually be an Android which why do we
care
oh and let's have a reset button so none
of this matters anyways and honestly I
feel like the reset button is the least
of this things problems because it was
almost like a meta commentary on how the
doctor kind of fix this thing so I can
almost applaud at that but man you know
from a starting interesting premise of
exploring the interior of the TARDIS
while it's all breaking down it just
falls apart hard number 13 a nightmare
and silver Neil Gaiman writing the
Cybermen this should have been great and
it just isn't it is a combination of
ideas that don't that feel like they
needed another pass
and some performance oh and or directing
decisions that just don't help the
inclusion of the kids Angie and RD they
shouldn't be there they contribute
absolutely nothing and Angie especially
is an infuriating character every time
she speaks I can't stand her
so they drag this whole thing down the
whole thing of mr. clever and this
cybernetic version of the doctor
fighting with the actual doctor for
control should be really cool and
compelling but it's not partially
because there isn't very much to
differentiate the performance from Matt
Smith between one and the other and I
it's just it's just one is the doctor
slightly angled down so he looks more
evil with blinky bits on his face but
he's the same guy because we've seen
Matt Smith's doctor go dark and get a
feel dangerous and this mr. clever just
feels like that I'm like you don't feel
like a different character because we've
seen these as aspects elements of the
doctor so that doesn't work
the Cybermen like the idea of if there's
even one if we can't kill we have to
blow up the planet I mean that's cool to
say I guess but they're not demonstrably
that much more interesting than we've
ever seen them up to this point it's got
Warwick Davis I mean that's nice it's
about all I got though number twelve the
rings of Akutan here's what I would say
I find this one somewhat just bland
uninteresting even the big key moment
which is the big speech from the doctor
doesn't really work because the sound
mixing is completely buggered and then I
do people might want to use British like
I usually throw that as a way to not
swale because that's what I wanted to
say but it is you can barely make out
what he's saying so even the supposed
best moment is completely screwed up and
everything else up to that point is just
you can't get invested in it meanders
around it doesn't seem to know what
point it's trying to make and it seems
to be trying to sell Clara but it's just
selling the idea of infinite possibility
that doesn't sell her as a character so
it fails and what it sets out to do and
it's not even that interesting to watch
number eleven I think we're out of the
really bad stuff and now we start
getting into the mediocrity and that is
a town called mercy I want to like this
one more I really do I like Ben Browder
a lot
I love Farscape I like the design on the
cyborgs I'm okay with the setting
overall I just just doesn't click it's
just kind of they're like okay so that
was a thing we did cool it's it's a kind
of a nothing of an episode it leaves
very little impression behind after you
watch it moving up one spot to number 10
the Crimson horror this is one and I
went into detail on this in my review
but this is one where one change and
this could have been good unfortunately
it just comes in as slightly undercooked
there's at least versus some of the
other stuff there's more decent elements
at play is the Pater Noster gang who I
enjoy they're some good strong
performances from the guest cast I mean
you know we've got Diana Rigg how bad
can it be and it's it's fine but it
could it could and should have been more
but it it reintroduces the doctor too
early from a starting premise of we
don't know where the doctor is but
something's going on and we know he's
somehow involved it should have taken
longer for him to come back so it could
have been a triumphant moment but he
comes back about halfway through and
then it's just like oh okay so business
as usual from here on then number 9 the
snowmen I'll give this one credit I
think better of it than I did before
this rewatch I think there's there's
more to it than I was giving it credit
for
before the doctor himself Matt Smith
gives a solid performance in this one
this is honestly my favorite iteration
of Clara at the very least through
series 7 my favorite iteration of Clara
that we get initially and I'd like the
setting I think it's fun I like some of
the whimsy in it but once we introduce
the ice governess things kind of spiral
a little bit and doesn't quite pull
together again after that and it's it's
one of the better Christmas specials but
if you know how little regard I hold the
Christmas specials in you'll realize
that's not really compliment coming from
me number eight the bells of st. John
strong performance from Matt Smith very
cool return of Richard II grant as a
great intelligence some neat ideas in
terms of hacking people adjusting
personality traits but the spoon heads
the killer Wi-Fi this version of Clara
none of that quite lands it's not awful
and I remember liking it quite a bit at
the time but I think it was just really
happy to have more Doctor Who back and
Matt Smith is still doing great in the
park but it's trying to do too much and
some of the things that it's doing don't
completely work and as a result it's
just kind of fine number seven the power
of three I think people are down on this
episode more than it deserves this
doesn't come apart until about the last
five minutes
and honestly up to that point I think
it's really clever I like what it does I
like what it does to build towards the
exit of Amy and Rory I like the idea of
this slow invasion where the doctor is
forced to come to earth and stay put for
a while and he hates it yeah we get we
get more of Brian and you know Rory's
dad and that's nice there's a lot of
good stuff here up until we get to the
conclusion which is rushed and doesn't
feel like a proper payoff to anything
and just doesn't work so I honestly up
and
about the last sub missing is pretty
solid and I think deserves a bit more
credit than people give it number 6 cold
war it's a pretty solid reintroduction
of the ice warriors
that's kind of out all I got it's what
once you know the premise it does pretty
much exactly what you'd think it would
do but it's buoyed by a couple of neat
ideas such as the ice warrior coming out
of it's out of its armor and some good
performances from people like david
warner and liam Cunningham so you know
that helps boost it a little but the
material overall is just so bland
well no bland bland is overly harsh it's
not bland it's just it's workman like it
fills the space it gets the job done but
it's there's nothing particularly
memorable about this one which is
unfortunate because like I said there's
some decent component pieces they just
nothing is is really there to really hit
you really give you a reason to remember
this one as a result I tend to forget
what series this happens in unless I
really think about it
number five dinosaurs on a spaceship I
probably put this one a lot higher than
most people would but I just find it fun
it's called dinosaurs on a spaceship it
is fun I love the bickering robots
that's so Douglas Adams I love that too
Jeff
we get Rory's dad which normally not
something I care for but he's just so
lovable I enjoy him quite a bit and you
know the doctors excitement I like the
assembling of sort of this ragtag team
with this big-game hunter and Nefertiti
I'm like why not it's a bit of a throw
caution to the wind let's just have a
good time adventure that is just fun and
enjoyable until it decides to get like
weirdly dark at the end and I'm not
saying the doctor can't be dark but for
the turn that it takes versus the tone
of the episode up to that point
it doesn't quite work but up until then
I find this one quite fun
number four angels take manhattan
logistical problems out though
but with this there's a there's a lot of
things that don't really make sense
although like people keep bring up in
the comments the idea of why why
couldn't the doctor ever go back and why
have we seen the doctor in New York and
other instances like it wasn't just New
York it was that specific time bit of
New York because that that was what was
all screwed up so you know that he could
still show up earlier like he did with
Martha to an earlier point in the
timeline in New York City and plus it's
reiterated within the same episode once
he has seen their graves he knows when
they die
could he feasibly have gone back and
visited them maybe but he couldn't take
them out because there he already knows
they're going to live their lives and
die so it's the recursive loop that's
already in there so that's not a
logistical problem I just had to get
that off my chest but there are plenty
of others though that don't quite make
sense the Statue of Liberty being the
big one literally and figuratively holy
cow but the emotion and this one is what
rings true the performances from Arthur
Darvill and Karen Gillan are really
really strong I mean they've been strong
throughout they've been great together
and they're really good here and they
sell that loss and Karen Gillan
especially and her goodbye to the doctor
really good Alex Kingston does great
work as River Song in this one it's the
performances and the emotionality that
is injected into what is happening that
elevates this and it does a lot to bring
it up and help paper over the fact that
significant parts of it don't make
anything sense number three probably the
only person on the planet who's gonna
put this one so high although I hear a
lot of people don't like my number two
that much either anyways this is a weird
series you got to give me some leeway on
it on this ranking number three is hide
I just enjoy this
I like the the 1970s you know sort of
paranormal investigation thing that
they've got going on I like the vibe of
the ghost story feel to it I think the
solution is kind of neat and clever I
think there's a lot of good atmosphere
in it I it's it's bizarre and doesn't
necessarily fit the story otherwise but
I do actually really like the idea of
this horrifying scary monster that the
doctor has been terrified of is just
trying to get back to its mate I just
like that it's it's as simple as that I
just like it
number two asylum of the Daleks a lot of
people seem to not like this one like a
lot I enjoyed this one I think the pace
is nice I think it's it's got a fun
adventure vibe to it for a lot of it I
honestly am completely I completely
support the characterization and the
handling of Amy and Rory's relationship
I understand the complaint so you don't
have to put them in the comments I've
heard them and I understand them I just
don't share them for me it works and I
honestly really enjoyed this episode
some people take a really deep dislike
to this one and I think I don't know how
much of that was the marketing at the
time I'm really building up the idea of
all these Daleks from all these eras
when it's not really about that they're
just in the background but as a story
unto itself
I enjoy this I think it's fun I think it
deals with its emotional core well I
like this version of car better than the
one that we were stuck with not quite as
much as governor's car but I do like her
I think the twist is in hindsight it's
obvious but I think it's pretty well
handled it's pretty clever I just enjoy
this one and number one name of the
doctor I really should have a lot more
praising to say about the number one
that I do but I said you know this isn't
a great series it's not but name of the
doctor is a
solid finale and Wow that cliffhanger at
the end holy cow like what a crazy
reveal what a wha
and also I do really enjoy what is going
on with the great intelligence I like
the idea that he's just so fed up with
the doctor beating him at every turn
that he's willing to die just to screw
with the doctor I like that I dig it
we got the painter nostril game back
pater noster gang back and I always
enjoy them they're not actually in all
that many good stories but I do enjoy
them and they're fun we get river and we
get some nice closure between her and
Matt Smith's doctor that works really
well I I do think this is a really solid
wrap-up for a very deeply uneven season
so that's series 7 yuri watched it
lately what do you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down in the comments let's
talk about it usual stuff to do like
subscribe share this around check out my
patreon you know all the stuff we also
don't have to do any of it cuz the end
of the day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]